uh my response that would be
both of our personalities we like to do
things our way
um
but we also are very aware that ego and
greed would be our biggest downfall so
if we really hold on to needing to be
right or wanting to break too much so
i think the thing we've done really well
so far and we continue to do is just
we always look for what's right so if
it's my idea kevin's idea someone else
is on the team
we welcome
disagreements and
we love to argue with each other because
we get better outcomes from it all um
i think the thing we do really well is
we just look for what makes sense and
what seems right versus oh i need to
hold on to this opinion because it was
my own
so is there a process
is there a process to a disagreement
there's just a lot honestly i've always
wondered that's cute it's really um
it's really not yeah it's very organic
and i think to match point we encourage
principal disagreement
amongst the team you know for i think
the magic kind of happens in the middle
of of that
um and it's just i think it's from our
athletic background just being kind of
innate and growth in us um
and it's kind of transferred and come
through a beam too well that gets back
to what i was actually thinking is that
of course i've known you guys for years
and um you know we i would call as
friends um
but i don't know how you guys met
about 10 years ago so we went to boston
college together um kevin played
baseball at bcs you know i played hockey
bc and
i guess we met we had a few classes
together um we joke i think there's a
few professors that would find it
we have a hello
we can't tell you the story but why not
it's just us
because it's really embarrassing because
some of our other investors might listen
to this and yeah and
that could be the end
uh we did a i'll just put it to you like
this we did a very very very very poor
job in front of a group of people uh in
a group project and
i've done a lot of embarrassing things
in my life and
that still is top of the list for most
modifying it
was it so you connected on this very
embarrassing thing
or you did it together
yeah i guess this really is how we
really met i mean we've seen each other
just you know in the athletic weight
room in the locker rooms and stuff like
that we're only friends though in
college very much yeah but somehow we
wound up in a marketing class together
we ended up in a group together so
there's a few of my teammates a couple
of kevin's teammates we were entering
playoffs their season was just starting
so they were traveling up and down the
coast we were you know heading to the
final stretch of our season
this project really wasn't top of mind
for either of us and the whole semester
the whole thing was based on helping a
business with whatever it is i think we
got paired up with the insurance company
and we're supposed to just essentially
like free interns
we never communicated all to that
company um and we showed up on the
presentation day and we played a clip
from the an office remember hold on one
guy on the baseball team we've met the
day before he's just like okay i got
this i know what we're going to do oh
great i thought i was going to be here
for a few hours cramming for this so we
show up
and he plays a video clip of the office
and there's like four or five of us and
we just it this is like a i don't know
like a marketing election first uh yeah
stadium seating in the class so he plays
a clip of the office and all this it
ends and we stare at each other we're
like
are you gonna you're gonna keep talking
about you said you got it and just
nothing we all just stared at each other
and
you know like that like giggling feeling
that you can't control when you're just
like totally mortified it just came over
everybody the whole class just beating
down staring at us and
that's how we met that was that's how we
met
that was the business together it was
the most i've never been like i feel it
felt like there's probably a couple
hundred balls that felt like a million
so you were you were doing a
presentation together yeah you could
call it that
got it got it and
matt you played
baseball hockey hockey i played baseball
and that was my junior year and i i
didn't i got drafted that year and i
wasn't
i didn't end up coming back from my
senior year i did later in life um
graduated but at that point in my life i
wasn't very concerned about my grades
well
you and like every other kid in the
world at some points at least in time
yeah it probably all depended on if a
parent cared about their grades because
if you left it up to the kid to care
about the grades
it's probably few and far between i
already agree with that yeah did you
guys think that you were going on to be
athletes is that part of it yeah that
was it for me i knew i was gonna get
drafted that year and i had a pretty
good understanding that i wasn't gonna
come back to school for my senior year
right away so
yeah it was like i said it was it wasn't
it definitely never wasn't number one on
my list but it probably wasn't number
two three four or five either in terms
of priorities
so then what was it about because like
that was
cop that was college right and then
you know beam is only
three or four years how many how many
years has been been around three years
really just about two and a half coming
up on three hundred
so you know i'm i'm not judging but you
guys didn't just get out of college
but so like what happened what happened
in college during this presentation that
you all connected on that then led to
starting beam was there something that
was it didn't have to do with um
supplementation and experimentation
within sports as it went along did you
stay connected did you
um
traveling this brotherhood of pants or
something i mean like how did you guys
stay it was kind of
it was kind of just serendipitous um we
didn't keep in touch at all when kevin
left we both played professional for a
little bit
um wound up out of sports sooner than we
were hoping because the injuries and
we just crossed past an apartment
building in boston that we just wound up
and bumped into each other to the
elevator and then seriously kevin i just
haven't yeah i actually had this crazy
storm my wife and i we lived in austin
to my
girlfriend at the time then fiance we
moved back to boston
and we were gone for a long week and i
won't bore you with the details of the
story i got a call like on a sunday
afternoon that was like hey um there's
two feet of standing water in your 10
ten uh
in the apartment on your tenth floor we
had all of our crap was ruined we had to
move out of the apartment immediately
and i moved into that building where
matt was in the seaport um if that
didn't happen we probably wouldn't be
here either yeah that was a serendipity
over there
yeah and then we just love all things
wellness and we started working out
together and
i totally want to ask about that um
because you both i mean matt you're more
into crossfit and lifting and kevin
you're a little more like endurance and
cardio stuff we did we did connect on
the crossfit stuff in the very beginning
um for sure in telling me that story
i've
i've had a lot of thoughts about this
where the universe just kind of sends
you signs all the time right and if we
pay attention there
and i do think that people
stay in our path that are meant to be
there and sometimes there's these near
misses where you see them
or where you don't see them but you're
at the same place same time like maybe
you could have had the story where you
were you lived in the same building you
didn't even know it but i don't know
something tells me that this kind of was
always meant to be because you know you
had this random presentation in college
you didn't even stay in touch all of a
sudden you see each other in the
elevator and
and so maybe it wasn't a conscious
synchronistic event or maybe it was i
mean how did you
what what happened when you saw each
other after so long of not staying
connected that uh what what did you do
when you saw each other
i think the first thing we did you were
training for an iron man with brook and
we worked out together um
that's a great story too actually we
were
i was i was trained rick and i were
training for what was that uh you're
welcome
yeah my wife brooke yeah yeah uh for
iron man mantra from blonde uh because
this is probably like
2016 yeah 2015. and
um we went deep in a very hard training
block where you're doing like
i don't know a lot of a lot of hours of
cardio on a weekly basis and one of the
workouts i'm sure you've probably done
to fart like danica where you're doing
five have you done those before yeah
five fourth a fartlek um yeah it's kind
of an interesting name it's a heart i'm
a girl it's actually it's it's swedish
for speedplay so it's like a five-minute
effort at like next pace two minutes
easy four minute effort at wide pace two
minutes a little bit harder harder
harder the effort gets shorter but
harder i mean i've done structures like
that but i haven't yeah so you haven't
called it a fart like though no i just
called it interval training
um
so we had a big fire light coming up and
uh we matt it was like hey i'll join you
on this workout i remember being like
dude
no with love and respect i don't know if
this is the one you want to just like
hop in and on if you're a big rock was
he as buff as he is now totally oh yeah
maybe maybe not quite as big as he is
now i haven't gotten into crossfit
he wasn't in marathon he didn't look
like a marathon runner we'll call him um
did he join me he hung on for
like 90 of it
um i remember i got back and brooke and
i were like damn that was like what a
what a savage that was like you have to
be a freak to be able to to deal with
that and i couldn't do anything for
about a month after that
an impromptu bartlett to know
your needs
but i think that like cemented like i
think matt and i like you know it's
a startup is really hard you know
there's
you just spend your whole day your every
week and moment of your day getting
kicked in teeth and i think like that
kind of for me it was like
a good indication of like all right this
person has like that
either has one or is missing that extra
chromosome to be able to do like this
like this craziness you know
yeah there's always been something just
like
the bond i guess through working out
summoner training even in hockey like
some of my best relationships have come
through the guys you know i do extra
workouts with